als Hauptaugenmerk meines Vortrags, sondern eher
als Grundlage für die Moral von morgen
- Pappel, eine Art angenehmer, also haben
wir ein ethisches System wie die Virusbaumwolle entwickelt,
das ein realistisches ethisches
System ist, und ich hoffe, dass uns dies auch
einige Einsichten geben wird  von der
metaphysik des geschädigten und es funktionierte
übrigens so hab ich euch kurz gesehen äh was
die moralischen herausforderungen gerade
über ethik denken was es genau um 50
beispiele gibt die man vielleicht so stark hervorbringt
recht aber die frage die ich stellen möchte  Sie
sollten mit mir zurückdenken, was Sie suchen,
um intuitive moralische Aussagen zu treffen. Wir liegen
richtig, falsch, und natürlich ist die Debatte
heute sehr heiß, es gibt viel Schlussaktivität,
und wir könnten die Positionen vielleicht in zwei Gruppen einteilen,
den Realisten einerseits und
den Imperialismus andererseits  Andererseits und in
antiken Positionen endete mit Beispiel,
weil es das ist, was auf ihn zutrifft, also
wie kommt es, dass dieser Anspruch
Ausgangspunkt sein kann, auch mehr Realismus
[Musik]
es in Frage kommt, wenn wh  Es macht
die Urteile darüber, wer objektiv
gut für wirklich wünschenswerte Objekte datiert ist. Wenn
der Grund nicht billig ist, ist es ein guter
Agent, der kreisförmig zu sein scheint, sodass Sie selbst
nicht die Frage beantworten, was die
moralische Güte gewährt, und für die erste
Art von gibt es viele  Ressourcen
Ressourcen und er hat eine Antwort, die
Zirkularität von Bürogeräten sein wird, also
möchten wir wissen, was es macht,
dass
sie darin gut sind  Mittel sind genau das, was
Güte ist, kennen Sie
Ihre menschliche Natur, aber darunter ist
eine Leistung des menschlichen Handelnden zu verstehen, diese
Leistung besteht in der
Erlangung einer bestimmten Art dynamischer Einheit
der Person und dies ist meine Verbindung zum
Konferenzthema so tugendhaft  wie
wir viele Male im Monat sagen werden, um eine
bestimmte Art von Gemeinschaft innerhalb der
psychologischen Merkmale zu erreichen, ob
Menschen und die biologischen Merkmale
, die ch  Stellen Sie uns vor, wie Sie sein können,
was ist, also wird es nicht spielen - wenn
wir nicht an eine kleinere Nähe denken,
wo es einen
Ausgangspunkt gibt, wie fangen wir mit
Abbadon Aristotelian
an
?  Bei solchen Fällen in der
Welt, aber die Fälle in der Welt sind
überraschend, weil
sie uns etwas enthüllen werden. Ich
dachte, dass die menschliche Natur
hier kein Beruf ist, der ganz
zentral ist, also kehren wir zu den Wünschen
der zurück  Ausgangspunkt Beispiele Beispiele für
Beispiele für Leistungen So
sagt Aristoteles, dass die Güte
eines Flötenspielers bei
Handwerkern jeder Größenordnung wie im Allgemeinen
bei jedem eingefangen wurde, bei dem ein Jagdgeschäft
in der Leistung
in der Funktion, die man ausübt, gut abschneidet
das ist jetzt ein guter ausgangspunkt
was das interessante an diesem
ansatz ist, dass wir uns davon überzeugt haben, dass
aristoteles ungefähr über biologie nachdenkt
Als eine Reihe von Prozessen
zu sehen und besonders relevant war für mich
sehr einfach
, ein Mensch zu sein
Sein und wieder bin ich nur
sehr nachsichtig in denselben
weiteren Erkundungen, die Ethik
für die nicht sendende Art von Wissenschaftlern haben
werden  Auf dem
Teil der Amtsinhaber und in der
Literatur, aber ich denke, ich werde ein paar
Dinge haben, die neu in Taya Baptists
berühmtem Land sind, unsere Community in unserer
gestarteten, also habe ich sie wieder zum Leben erweckt, nur
um Ihre Erinnerung daran aufzufrischen, aber auch
um Sie daran zu erinnern  Spüren Sie, wie seltsam es uns vorkommt
zu sehen, dass der Mensch
Sie nur prüft, achtsam opfert, viel weniger
intuitiv, als dass es den Anschein haben könnte, dass
Menschen seine Funktion haben, und es gibt
einige Dinge, die c sind  Ich habe dieses Gefühl der
Schwierigkeit mit der Vorstellung,
dass Menschen eine Funktion haben, durch eine qualifizierende Aussage aufgenommen,
also habe ich auf dieser Folie die letzten
Worte von sich selbst hervorgehoben, dass jeder Mensch
eine Funktion hat, die nicht notwendig ist, wie der
erste echte Film aussehen könnte,
und ich habe hier angefangen  Ich möchte sagen, dass er
nicht ganz hässlich ist, also um rechtzeitig
zu erklären, dass Menschen
bewusst sind, was nicht vorausgesetzt ist, wie Sie
sehen können, wenn Aristoteles
Menschen mit menschlichen Organen vergleicht, und ich
werde sagen, dass dies als nicht hilfreich gilt
Analogie, also denken wir, ich denke,
Sachs, dass Menschen die Funktionen sind, die
funktionieren, und diese
Funktion als eine Funktion, was ein Problem,
einfach für irgendetwas, zum Beispiel, was
das Problem ist
Umgang mit der Veränderung des menschlichen Körpers
als Funktionär, der der
Funktion des Organismus innerhalb von 50 Ts dient,
damit wir einem Zweck dienen können, der
außerhalb von ihm selbst und unmittelbar
partikulär ist  rly hier, so viel wie es gibt
, können Sie
nicht meinen, ein Zweck, der über
das Freisein hinausgeht, wird sein, was die Unterstützung sein wird, ein
Mensch, der Sie sein würden. Ich meine, es
sieht nicht so aus, als könnten wir uns vorstellen, dass
Sie ein Teil davon sein können  etwas anderes
, das den Zweck eines Films erfüllt, und
insbesondere innerhalb des Aristoteles-Systems besteht das
Problem darin, dass Aristoteles ziemlich
deutlich macht, dass Substanzen nicht schwer
für Substanzen sein können, also wissen Sie, dass ich denke,
dass Sie an dieser Stelle öffnen können und wir
fragen uns, ob sie es getan haben  eine
Funktion, die Art von Funktion
[Musik]
funktioniert, die einem
erfolgreichen Scheitern unterliegt und das heißt, und wir
haben erfolgreich gescheitert,
es muss zielgerichtet sein, also ist das
Erreichen des Ziels Erfolg und das Nichterreichen des
Ziels Erfolg und das brauchen wir  zu
[Musik]
[Musik],
weil ich dachte, dass ich Zeit damit verbringen würde, zu
streiten, dass ein Ziel
in Ägypten nicht vorschlägt, die Drohne ist der Standpunkt
der gewöhnlichen Menschen, und dies ist
uns seltsam, wenn die Leute denken, wir
wüssten es
und Google, es sei denn, sie sehen einen Agenten
, der Emotionen auslöst
auch in der Natur vorhanden,
also sagt uns sein Argument, dass zwischen
natürlichen Prozessen, die große Ziele haben,
selbst wenn es keinen Agenten gibt, der
diesen Gott saugt, und um dieses Argument zu beweisen
, uns einfach ein Gedankenexperiment fragt,
wo die Aktivität des Schiffbaus, um das
wir Geld bitten, ist  Eingebaute Lebensmittel, so dass Lebensmittel
Expo versuchsweise Schiffe und sogar ein
Mädchen bauen, ohne dass sie alt sind, also ist es eine
Art Vorstellung, dass
natürliche Prozesse Ziele haben können,
die als Unglaube bezeichnet werden, weil
es nichts Gutes gibt,
also lassen Sie uns einfach wichtig, dass das
festgestellt wurde  Es gibt zielgerichtete
Prozesse in der Natur,
die einen Agenten haben, genau dieser Prozess, der
in der Natur nicht verarbeitet werden kann, kann dies instanziieren
Idee, dass es zielgerichtete
natürliche Prozesse gibt, und ich habe
hier nicht explizit angefangen, aber ich denke, was wäre, wenn Stadt
ist, dass es Prozesse in der Natur gibt,
denen wir einen Namen geben, der
für sofortige Schattierungsarten von
Aktivitäten oder Prozessen ungeeignet ist, aber es stellt sich erneut die
Frage  Das Ende im
Anfangsprozess markiert, wenn die
Möglichkeit besteht, und ich nehme an, wir haben eine
gewisse Vorstellung davon, dass unsere markierten und
veranlassten Endpunkte in einem natürlichen
Prozess die Periodizität des aber
dennoch leicht erschrockenen Denkens ist,
dass das Ende
des funktionalen Films das Natürliche ist  oder
direktive Prozesse des Todes das Ende des
Lebens
und wieder vermenschliche ich mit dieser
Art von Argumentation, weil die meisten von
uns wirklich funktional sind, aber ich denke, wir
finden es zu verführerisch in einer Art und Weise, wie wir
damit nach Italien gehen, vielleicht so ist es
das  und hier müssen wir diese
Metaphysik gesehen haben, wo er uns sagt, dass das Leben
für andere ein Prozess ist, der nicht
linear ist, sondern einen Auf- und
Abstieg hat  ent und dass Auf- und
Abstieg die Periodizität des Prozesses bestimmen,
also ist das Leben für einen Organismus ein
Entwicklungsprozess, jener gespenstische Tag vor
der vollständigen Bildung des Organismus, so
offen gesagt, der Lebenspunkt, der
entlang dieses Prozesses der Moment des
Aufstiegs die Fruchtentwicklung war  und dann
gibt es einen Prozess der Verschlechterung,
bei dem die Verwendungen, wie ich sie so ausdrücke, bedeutet, dass
sie den Mantel und die organischen Materialien verlieren, bevor sie den Halt verlieren.
Das
Ziel des Lebens,
das als Prozess und chemischer
Prozess konzipiert ist, ist also nicht das, sondern
wenn Sie gesendet werden  Wo der Organismus
so weit ist, ist, dass Iris oft
Güte in der Ausführung eines bestimmten
Prozesses finden möchte, selbst im Fall meiner Güte habe
ich zwei Dinge gesehen, dass es einen
Prozess und eine Leistung des Menschseins gibt
, die vorher gut nicht gut waren
und gut oder nicht gut funktioniert, wird es sein,
was gut ist, um es als Kriterium zu verwenden,
um es von den schlechten mit den
Prozessen zu unterscheiden und mehr Güte und
ihre Fremdpa zu melden  Es ist wichtig,
und ich betone, dass dieser Prozess
, der das menschliche Leben ist, ein natürlicher
Prozess ist, der als Mädchen, aber es gibt kein
Alter, das nervt, dass behauptet wird,
dass es das Ziel des Prozesses nervt,
aber der Prozess ist natürlich gut
geleitet  und wir sollten die fragen
stellen wo ist das ziel wenn wir
dieses mädchen schon mal in funktion sortiert finden
argument so gut wie dass es
im prozess so zu finden ist anstatt
extern die frage zu haben ist wie
finden wir dieses ziel  internationaler prozess
in den natürlichen zielgerichteten prozessen des
lebens und hier beginne ich meinen mehr
interpretativen park was mit der
verpfändeung des papiers zu tun hat, das ich am anfang mehr als so erlitten habe,
außer dass er das nicht tat
ist der moralische agent mit meinem agenten, der
funktioniert  fungiert als Maß für die
Leistung des Weltakteurs, die der
moralische Akteur erhält, indem er
die Funktionsmerkmale des
charakteristischen Wesens, das Menschsein ist, gut erfüllt,
und wenn wir nur vorher wissen, wie
Welche Funktion würden wir tun,
bevor ich wie Sokrates anfing, also wie
war das und wir sollten danach streben, wenn wir
als Menschen und die anderen gute Leistungen erbringen wollen,
gibt eine Definition, die
wieder und es ist die Passage der Aktivität
des Resorts in Übereinstimmung  mit oder nicht
ohne rationales Prinzip, aber was
hier fehlte, ist die explizite Aussage, wann
ein guter Agent wilde Aktivitäten ausführt,
die charakteristisch
dafür sind, dass ich wer auch immer
bin  Wir stellen fest,
was das Prinzip ist, dass wir das
noch haben müssen, und unsere
Lebensleistung, um das zu erreichen -
gut, und hier bringe ich Sie zu einer
anderen Anlage, wo eine Art System
durch seine Theorie der Wahrheit im Allgemeinen
so ist  Daran halte ich fest, und wenn wir danach
suchen, sollten wir uns
die Tauben ansehen,
die uns von unserem
Vorläufer übergeben wurden  ssors und teste sie und versuche
herauszufinden, welche
Rätsel, wenn du Dinge verwendest und sie irgendwie
mit Gebrauch anpasst, so wahrgenommen wurden
, dass nur die glaubwürdigen die
schlüssigen Meinungen vertreten und diejenigen
, die dem Widerspruch folgen, diskutieren wir gerade
und so sind wir  Holen Sie sich jetzt Bergbau,
der Tipp im Wesentlichen dieser Ansicht ist, dass
Kohärenz eine innere Kohärenz innerhalb eines
Systems von Überzeugungen ist, die von unseren Vorgängern empfangen wurden,
und das ist alles, was wir
nebenbei erfahren, dass wir nicht darüber hinausgehen können.
Das ist das Beste, was wir tun können, um
Kohärenz zu finden im Gegensatz zu
Ich glaube, wir können darüber hinaus nur
genau hören, wo wir empfangen werden, und dann die
Verbindung sehen, aber abgesehen davon
möchte ich mich darauf konzentrieren, wie es zum
Verschwinden des Geistes kommt, indem wir wenig anwenden,
so dass die Überzeugungen, die unserem Leben
innewohnen, inhärent sind
wir finden es durch unsere physische jetzt
verallgemeinern
, sagen wir, das ist im Grunde aber das gleiche
Essen, das ein Künstler gerne hören würde,
es ist unter unseren Säcken von Überzeugungen, in der Tat,
die Welt ist es auch  Die Angelegenheit, die es
uns ermöglicht, mehr Artikel als Kohärenz
zwischen den mehr Leben zu finden, haben wir mehr Stiefel
für Graseis, genauso
wie die physische Welt und die
plastische oder grundlegende Kohärenz zu beschreiben,
warum ist dies für meine Frage
des Wie relevant?  Der gute Agent wird zu einem guten Agenten
, der die Funktion, ein
guter Mensch zu sein,
gut ausführt. Danke, dass Sie wissen, wie man
diese Funktion gut ausführt. Sie wissen, dass Sie
wissen müssen, was zu sagen ist, dass dies einer sein könnte
Bestimmte Werte als unsere
Art, die Tatsachenwelt und
Werte zu erreichen, ist auch entscheidend, dass Benutzer,
die mir sagen, wann es ist, dass ein Agent
tatsächlich versucht, das
Morgenessen in dem Sinne umzusetzen, dass das
natürlich Angenehme das
ist, was von moralischen Agenten entworfen wird
ohne interne Konflikte,
also besteht der Konflikt hier nicht zwischen
Themen wie „Ich möchte bei dem Medium sein“
und denen, die diese Konferenz aufgebaut haben,
aber „Ich kann nicht gesegnet sein“ sagten, dass es nicht so ist
Konflikt ist Konflikt
zwischen Wünschen. Wenn ich also eine gute Mutter
bin, würde all mein innerer Wunsch
und ich bin mir bewusst, dass ich natürlich den Wunsch
habe, bei dieser Konferenzidentität
den Konflikt mit jedem anderen Design zu wiederholen, das
möglicherweise in der Zeit sein könnte  Kohärenz
, die charakterisiert und dass Überzeugungen
Backport auch Räumungspreis des
Marktes ist, ist die Art von Kohärenz,
die den wirklich guten moralischen Agenten charakterisiert
Die Agentenergebnisse,
aber mit dem, was und mit dem Punkt handelt, ist kein
natürlicher Zustand, der eher wie ein guter, schlechter moralischer Zustand ist
eine bestimmte Fähigkeit oder
Reichtum in dem Land, das wir führen und wie
es ist, ist der Train Awards auch kein feines
Mittel, ohne das Rundschreiben, sondern mithilfe von
Rationalität, also Rationalität, Cholesterin zu
urteilen  g Die Kohärenz zwischen Bewohnern und
Führern, die dabei hilft, ihre Fähigkeit
zu fördern, Rationalität zu verfolgen, hilft uns dabei,
die Kohärenz zwischen dem, was wir
wollen, zu bestimmen und unser Verhalten so zu verkaufen
, dass wir beim
Versuch, das Ziel zu erreichen, das wir
uns jetzt gesetzt haben, wie gut waren  Hängt das alles mit
der Frage der Objektivität meiner
Werte zusammen? Kanada hat mit den Patronen begonnen
.
In Bezug auf unsere Werte hatte ich keine
Ahnung, aber
jeder hat ein geistiges Bild,
das es geschafft hat, die Idee nicht zu verwenden
Das, was ich angefangen habe, nennen wir einen Ureinwohner,
wenn die Aktivität der
Seele im Einklang steht. Die Schlüsselwörter
hier sind Seele und Hauptprinzip, nicht
übersetzen. Der Punkt ist, dass
Seele und rationales Prinzip uns Koordinaten geben,
innerhalb derer die Kohärenz besteht
Zu unseren Wünschen gehört es,
diese Koordinaten zu erreichen, einerseits die
biologische Natur, die wir als
Menschen haben, die Kraft oder
Grenzen saugt  Die Art von Wünschen braucht
Fähigkeiten, die wir haben, und andererseits
die Latke-Normativität
der Vernunft, zum Beispiel die Steuerbeschränkungen
, schränken das ein, was wir wollen, und
wünschen die Auswirkungen, daher sind diese beiden
Koordinaten wichtig, weil sie
allen Menschen gemeinsam sind, Heiligkeit und
Seele und durch Logik
Macher und alle deine Wesen Rationalität
mindestens Satellit weiter und das
zu Koordinaten, die allen
Menschen gemeinsam sind, die argumentieren, dass moralische
Güte auch allen
Menschen gemeinsam ist. Interessant ist also
unsere Position, dass das Molekül
verdächtig ist, sich so fortzubewegen  ist ein
bestimmtes Zeichen, das
sich von der Güte anderer
Lebensformen unterscheidet und zum Beispiel nicht von Außerirdischen
, die unsere biologische Ausstattung
und unsere 22 Arten nicht teilen, aber es ist
auch objektiv, warum ist es objektiv,
weil wir alle innerhalb unserer Spezies
die biologische Ausstattung teilen, die wir haben  ein 90
weiter, wenn der gute Mensch
eine der Aktivitäten des Menschseins ausführt
, die der natürliche Prozess ist
zielgerichtet ist es in der Welt so
sehr betont das ist der Unterschied
zwischen gespielt netter Baumwolle wo auch immer und
lass die Telefonzelle ist in einem anderen Wort
für das erste wo ich sah was schön ist
für mich dabei die Funktion
die uns als Menschen so auszeichnet
Was wirklich gut
ist, ist die Art von Dorset,
dass die Regel und ein ziemlich guter Mensch
ein Mensch ist, der die menschliche
Funktion erfüllt, bei der der Mensch, der das,
was wir sagen, für ein kurzes
Leben verlässt, neben uns lebt  Der Wunsch nach
dem Guten und das ist etwas, das erreicht werden kann
, hat zu einem Training geführt, also müssen
wir warten, um die Disharmonie zwischen
unseren Wünschen zurückzubringen, um Widersprüche und
Konflikte zwischen ihnen zu vermeiden, und wie können wir dies tun,
indem
wir einerseits die biologische Veranlagung andererseits erwürgen könnten
Seite mit Nachrichten von Prashanti ist es,
wenn Rationalität unsere Wünsche,
unsere psychologischen Zustände, unseren Glauben an
die Art der Einheit dieses Alters formt,
jetzt ist es die Einheit, die dy sein muss  namic,
weil es ein Prozess ist, der
nie endet, also beginnt es, wenn wir anfangen,
unsere Söhne auszubilden, und es ist eine ständige
Aktivität, die wir ausüben werden, aber dieses
Ziel, es ist ein Gefühl, gut zu leben
, das ein Ziel ist, das wir alle teilen,
insofern wir es innerhalb unserer Spezies teilen
biologische Zusammensetzung, die wir haben, sowie